so fast-forward mister pics to the
Sunday talk shows in Ambassador Susan
Rice she blamed this attack on her video
in fact she did it five different times
what was your reaction to that I was
stunned my jaw dropped and I was
embarrassed congressional hearings on
the September 2012 attack on the US
consulate in Benghazi have concluded
four Americans including ambassador
Christopher Stevens were killed in the
attack in 2012 supporters of Barack
Obama and then Secretary of State
Hillary Clinton say that the hearings
led by Republican representative darrell
Issa of California were nothing more
than a partisan attempt to smear the
current president and a likely contender
in the 2016 election whether you agree
with that or not here are three reasons
why Benghazi still matters to all
Americans what difference at this point
does it make the Benghazi attack marks
the first time in more than three
decades that a u.s. ambassador was
killed in the field yet after these
hearings in the State Department's own
accountability Review we still don't
know why the consulate was so poorly
protected and why the military didn't or
couldn't respond pleading incompetence
or the fog of war just isn't an answer
what difference at this point does it
make even after it became clear that the
YouTube video the innocence of Muslims
had nothing to do with Benghazi Hillary
Clinton invoked it as the cause of the
attack at a memorial service for the
slain Americans and President Obama told
the United Nations that everyone should
condemn those who slander the Prophet of
Islam what difference at this point does
it make how does the murder of an
ambassador to a country we helped
liberate reflect on the way that we got
involved in Libya
President Obama dispatched forces
without consulting Congress as US
involvement in Syria and elsewhere heats
up the absolute lack of a coherent much
less constitutional foreign policy will
only lead to more tragedies both in the
Middle East and throughout the world for
reason TV I'm Nick